[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 hace cinco años el
movimiento mitu sacudió Hollywood hasta
sus cimientos Aunque el sector cultural
estuvo a la cabeza de este movimiento
inició desde entonces una conversación
mundial sobre el sexismo al acoso sexual
y la misoginia nuestras colegas de la
cadena hermana en inglés estrenaron un
programa especial para hablar del legado
de mitú y preguntaron a la investigadora
y profesora al occidental College de Los
Ángeles Caroline hellman si cinco años
después ha cambiado algo escuchamos su
respuesta yo diría en general tal vez
esto es una toma drástica pero el
movimiento Me too es un movimiento de
campo en el sentido de que los
movimientos sociales para ser eficaces
tienen que en primer lugar aumentar la
conciencia que ya se logró hacer pero en
segundo lugar poner en marcha mecanismos
de rendición de cuentas que sea en
Hollywood o en una política pública y al
final ese segundo objetivo no se ha
cumplido así que me fijo en los
indicadores como el hecho de que solo el
1% de los violadores se verá un día
dentro de una cárcel y en Hollywood en
particular no hemos vistos cambios
drásticos en términos de quién está
dirigiendo las cosas detrás de los
bastidores Así que no es un misterio que
en una encuesta reciente realizada por
women infield el 69% de las mujeres de
la industria afirman haber sufrido acoso
o violencia sexual en los últimos años
no quiero ser demasiado pesimista pero
el movimiento aumentó la conciencia pero
no cambió la cultura
vamos a hablar ahora de un mítico
cabaret francés que desapareció en los
años 90 pero que fue clave para muchos
artistas sudamericanos la cantautora
Violeta Parra el artista cinético Jesús
Soto o el grupo venezolano los kierpa
todos pasaron por París y convirtieron a
la escala el lugar inspiró un documental
que nos descubre a nos da una multitud
de personalidades latinas que
encendieron las noches parisinas y que
en muchos casos fallecieron antes de
estrenarse El filme el informe es de
nuestra periodista Erika olavarría
la música latinoamericana resuenan las
cajas del puesto de Beach en el mercado
de las pulgas de santuan en París
representa un 25% de sus ventas
son sobre todo personas de una cierta
edad que tienen experiencia y
conocimientos muy profundos de la música
si la música Sudamericana estuvo de moda
en París desde los 50 se debió sobre
todo a la desaparecida scal un cabaret
que funcionaba en el distrito 6 de París
aquí tocaron Rafael gayoso y su grupo
Los machucambos que compraron el sitio
los 60 que a Gabriel García Márquez rey
barreto y hasta Violeta Parra
acaba de estrenar un documental que
resucita este sitio olvidado donde hoy
funciona un bar que nada tiene que ver
con América Latina
creo que una de las historias más
importantes para la propagación de lo
que aquí ocurrió en América Latina es la
historia de los párragos
Violeta
y sus hijos Isabel y Ángel vinieron a
Francia y cuando volvieron a Chile
regresaron con nueva música de Venezuela
andinas
el charango el 4 la quena instrumentos
que no eran considerados en Chile fue un
verdadero aporte Y eso se propagó por
toda América Latina
mezcal era parado obligada para los
artistas sudamericanos que aterrizaban
en París como el Vita delgado que llegó
en 1995
por los caminos
y cuando llego wow Voy a cantar en la
escala ya no era lo mismo Ya Rafael
había vendido la el público no era ese
mismo público apasionado con la música
latinoamericana este lugar
me transmite todo eso también todo la
venezolana no los conoció a todos pero
bebió de la música de los artistas del
scal y aún interpreta sus temas se
siente testigo privilegiada de un pasado
glorioso que pretende transmitir a la
nueva generaciones yo siempre seré
cerramos Este programa con los estrenos
musicales que nos llamaron la atención
esta semana empezando con el sencillo
que celebrará la reunión de la banda de
pop Punk blanco entonces estadounidenses
comenzarán su muy esperada Gira Mundial
el próximo 11 de marzo y pasarán por
Perú chile Argentina Colombia Paraguay
Brasil y México
[Música]
del lado del Planeta Rafael británico
stormi estreno haydense que el primer
adelanto de su tercer álbum This is what
I mean que llegará el 25 de noviembre
[Música]
y con el tema nace el DJ productor
portugués branco hace cantarla a cabo
verdena elai nos ofrece un videoclip
lleno de baile y alegría que grabaron en
agosto en el festival o sol de caparica
Nos despedimos con una colaboración
entre dos super estrellas el dominicano
ozuna y la colombiana Shakira con tan al
dolor y al despecho al ritmo de la
bachata en monotonía Gracias a ustedes
por su confianza y sigan con nosotros
hay más cultura en trans 24 y France
24.com
fue culpa tuya ni tampoco mía
fue culpar al monotonía Nunca dije nada
pero me dolía
yo sabía que esto pasaría
tú lo tuyo y haciendo lo mismo siempre
buscando